i was in kauai man kauai hawaii
and a man i met a man by a smoothie shop
and he was a shaman
you know he was off work smoothie guy
shaman guy
and next thing you know him him and his
old lady got me back at their joint they
got out of
you know kind of a low-key child care
kind of center also but they smoked they
have dmt over there
and they had that meow dmt
that smoky treat baby that brain
smoothie you know what i'm talking about
that buck can turn your whole life into
a damn skill crane baby in the claw the
lord comes out
and just picks things out of you that he
don't want to be there anymore
and one of the things that
the lord's mighty arm picked right out
of me was my desire to smoke cigarettes
because dmt i find it'll put the wheels
on your once
sometimes your very core has once inside
of it
it has things it wants to do
and if they just don't they don't have
the wheels it don't have the downhill
they don't have the gradient
but that dmt will get in there and do
that dirty work
you know it'll tickle your sister but
buy her a house you know what i'm saying
it does the things that you can't really
you don't want to do and that's what it
did for me man it got inside of me and
i went from literally each day i'd be in
my head like okay am i gonna and i
wasn't a heavy smoker
but i'd smoke a couple at night
and i had a crutch i would smoke when i
didn't want to
that was it i was smoking i didn't want
to
and anytime i had a problem or an
uncertainty
or a non-surety
or anything i would just i would go
smoke i it became my god in a weird way
when i had a question a worry a thought
a concern
or a positive feeling let's smokeless
smoke oh let's celebrate let's smoke oh
damn
bummer let's smoke it became where i
went when i had a feeling of any sort
so it was so nice when it disappeared i
mean literally
it just that that that five course meal
baby that five meow
dmt just took it completely out of my
my history and so that's what i think
that that kind of stuff can do is that
uh
it's the librarian inside of you
that we all need hope you enjoyed that
video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one